awesome well let's get started here and
we can uh
let people
come in from the waiting room as they
join as well
but hi everybody thank you so much for
joining us today welcome to the rstudio
enterprise community meetup our energy
meetup today
i'm rachel calling in from boston i'm
actually at the our studio office today
in the seaport
if you just join now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello maybe where you're
calling in from
i like to just let people know at the
beginning if you want to turn on live
transcription
for the meetup you can do so in the zoom
bar below if you just press more
um but to go through a brief agenda
we'll have uh some short introductions
of the meetup and welcome everyone here
our introduction to functional data
analysis with santiago rodriguez
and then lots of time for questions and
open discussion at the end as well
so just a reminder this meetup will be
recorded
too so it will be shared to the rstudio
youtube i'll put it on the meetup
discussion and on linkedin
so to ask questions if you don't want to
be part of the recording you can always
use the slido link that i'll share in
just a moment in the chat
yeah you could put your name in there
too if if you want and i can call on you
to ask the question live or you could
ask anonymously
but for anybody joining for the first
time welcome this is a friendly and open
meetup environment for teams to share
the work they're doing within their
organizations
teach lessons learned network with each
other
really just allow us all to learn from
each other
so thank you all so much for making this
a welcoming community too
we really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate we can hear
from everyone
regardless of your level of experience
or the industry that you work in
so if you ever have suggestions or
general feedback please let me know too
i'll share a few other links in
the chat as well where you can do so
but with that thank you all again for
joining us i would love to turn it over
to our speaker santiago rodriguez
santiago
and i are friends from linkedin that's
actually how we first met santiago is a
data scientist in the marketing
department at consumers energy a
michigan based public utility
hi rachel hi everybody
and that's exactly right i reached out
to rachel one day because she had a
really interesting post on some
functions in r that i hadn't heard of
before i thought they were great so i
just sent a hey cool post and uh
just end it up here
maybe that's inspirational for somebody
if you have something you want to share
reach out there's a community
um okay so let's get started
our agenda today is going to cover some
introductions i'm going to introduce
myself the topic a little bit about
consumers energy
because i'm using some of their data so
i wanted to give them a shout out
a definition as to what functional data
analysis is
and then
the meat of the presentation is really
examples and implications of the present
of a functional data analysis this
method of analysis
and then we'll wrap up with some
resources in case anybody's interested
in how i got started
all right allow me to introduce myself a
little bit further i was born in ecuador
south america
i saw somebody in the chat who's from
columbia hello neighbor
um
i grew up in south florida
and i've lived in dallas texas for
seven years or so
i'm a bachelor from florida state
university and a master's in statistics
from texas a m
i currently work as a data scientist at
marketing
and i've had the pleasure of working
across different industries primarily
because i'm a learner and i
i love learning new things and different
industries different functions and then
when i'm out at work i'm primarily
reading
usually stats books and if it's not
stats books it's uh
fiction nonfiction um i like to travel
this year my wife and i
have dedicated time to traveling and i
love the fish i grew up in south florida
you know there's a body of water
around every corner
allowing me to introduce consumers
energy they're sort of
they're the sponsor of the data for this
presentation
it's a public utility founded in
michigan
they serve the majority of michigan's
residents
and have a generation capacity of about
six gigawatts
and then about today
uh my talk will be primarily descriptive
non-technical
we won't get into math or code really
it's all about
what is
a functional data analysis and how can
you use it what are applications
and my goal today is to introduce this
relatively young branch of
um
and then
show you that it has value that it can
add value that it's worth your time to
explore and
uh maybe learn as well
and i got started with this i wanted to
share that really quickly i'm by no
means an expert on functional data
analysis i've been
playing around with this stuff for a few
months probably close to a year
and um
in the utility space meter reads are our
primary data source for a lot of things
and
uh the time series nature
of uh
of meter reads
allow you to do a couple of different
interesting things if you're a time
series person you have decompositions
and other more traditional stuff i found
that
uh
functional data analysis with meter
reads was such a perfect
combination
and i'll show you some of these examples
in a bit
as far as logistics i've added little
break points into the presentation
partly to give me a break i get a glass
of water if i need and if you have any
questions you can ask a question um
in that section that way
you don't forget or i don't forget what
the heck i was talking about
and maybe it's a little bit more
relevant in that point in time
all right first up
this is an academic section sort of it's
a definition what can we do with
functional data analysis
it's the only
math
formula formula you'll see
today
and
it's useful up front before we get into
applications to define what this is what
functional data analysis is
and fda
is uh that's the acronym fda
functionality analysis it's an analysis
of information on curves and functions
for our purposes today we're going to
highlight curves
um but if you work in let's say with
spatial data you can use functions
um as well
functional data analysis is essentially
a non-parametric flexible regression
technique
that is used to approximate a curve you
know what
give me a second
okay here we go
um it's used to approximate a curve or a
function via a linear combination of
basis functions it looks like a
regression formula you have coefficients
and
points right data
in this case there's a there's a slight
tweak
where what we're trying to do is using
these red dots in this case these are
meter reads our data
using the data we're going to fit a
curve
right we're going to approximate a curve
using
bases functions and that's that fee
function in the formula it's that
non-parametric function and has the form
of the bottom right graph it looks like
lines um
and that's that's essentially it i don't
want to get too into the weeds here
you have a formula you have coefficient
coefficients that you estimate uh you
can do your usual stuff like these
squares
and then you have these the key here is
these this fee function that does
something that creates these curves
right and then you fit your data to with
those
naturally the question is all right we
fit these curves now what can we do with
these curves and it turns out you can do
quite a bit actually you can do
descriptive stats max min media and
variance
confidence intervals
you can do interpolation
things such as connecting the dots right
if you have meter reads and you want to
show a line instead of using the default
plotting method you could use functional
data analysis and connect the dots with
a little bit a little bit more smoothly
you can do extrapolation
uh functionally that looks like
functional regression if you want to do
some inferential type work if you're
doing some predictive work you can use
gams if you've ever used that you're
using functional data analysis on the
back end that uses cubic splines
a relatively newer approach is
clustering you can cluster the curves
and then if you're doing a time series
analyses you can use some of these
techniques as part of that as well
and here's the pitch right uh i think
it's worthwhile to explore functionality
analysis i know i found it useful
and it's another tool in your toolbox
and if a question comes along from a
stakeholder or something you find
something
you have potentially a better fitting
tool for the job
and if you've ever worked with your
hands and you've never built anything
you know that
the right tool makes the job so much
easier
[Music]
as far as fitting the curve as far as
the method goes it's quite flexible
it uh allows you to fit a curve via
those that feed function right that uh
non-parametric function a number of
different ways uh four-year basis are
really good for
periodic data
in this case meter reads tend to be
periodic or semi-periodic there's some
kind of cyclicality to things so it's a
it's good for that
e-splines a common or cubic splines
wavelets etc and then it's not only
about fitting the curve it's about
fitting the right curve right you want
to make sure you uh
you fit
you've accounted for residuals you're
fitting the right curve you're not over
fitting you're not under fitting and
there's a couple ways to fit the optimal
curve you have least squares
methodology as well as a penalization
technique
and then
arguably the coolest thing about
functional data analysis and the curves
that you fit
is that those curves are differentiable
now
uh at first i didn't realize
how useful that could be
and i kind of glossed over it and i've
recently gone back and learned more and
explored that area further because it
opens up a treasure chest of information
i think
some areas uh have experience working
with the rivets for example engineers
might look at rates of change
[Music]
physicists use derivatives often right
but if you work like i've worked
primarily in
commercial functions marketing finance
operations i haven't had a need that to
look at derivatives but it really is
interesting and i have an example of
that
in a bit so we have our first stopping
point i don't know if there are any
questions
if not i'm just going to grab a glass of
water
i can check over on slido but just to
remind everyone if you want to ask
questions either anonymously or with
your name
um you can do so on slido and i'll put
the link in the chat again
but the short link is
rs
td dot io slash meetup dash questions
put that there again there's a question
in the chat here about overfitting
that's that's definitely possible
if you were
going to do any sort of uh
if you were just connecting the dots
and you probably wouldn't care too much
about the fit but if you're doing
anything inferential or you you wanted
um
to take into account for overfitting or
underfitting i would suggest uh doing a
like
split the data
your typical hypertuning try different
number of basis functions
see which one has the
least
the best like sum of squares error
you could also use the penalization
technique that's i found that to be
probably the best approach
you can you can fully
you can fit a fully parameterized model
uh but with the penalty
here you account for
the overfitting or under fitting
i found that to be more powerful
i don't want to get like too into the
weeds but
hopefully that answers your question uh
in short in summary there are ways to
account and address
under fading and overfitting
and feel free to
unmute yourself if you want to add
context to questions too or raise your
hand on zoom and it can call on you
it should let you unmeet yourself
there was an anonymous question that was
what is the sample size you need to fit
the curves
good question uh
let's see i am working on stuff on the
side so everything i'll share after this
section
are snippets of applications that i'm
working on
as proof of concepts at work
um and i've worked with
millions of records
because you figured time series data can
go it gets so big so fast
or
you can work just 24 points right if i
if i'm working with summarized meter
reads let's say i have
um
that's actually a really funny question
is it it's a perfect segue into the next
section um let's say i have a year's
worth of meter reads i summarize them
by day right so i do the uh the mean by
hours
for the 24 hours and i'll end up with 24
points right that's like the
the slide the picture we saw earlier
with those red dots there are 24 red
dots one for each of the data each of
the hours
that's all that's all you need
to fit the curve
um if you wanted to do a little bit more
maybe some differential work like build
confidence intervals then just having
those 24 summarized points won't do you
any good because you have no way to
construct
um
like a standard deviation you don't have
that a sigma matrix
so you can work with
you'll see this in a second you can work
with the summarized information in just
the 24 points in this example or you can
work with all the data and then you have
access to more information you can do a
little bit more
but
depending on your machine depending on
your hardware that gets pretty out of
control quickly
and i'll show you in a second i'll try
to remember to
bring that up
i noticed well you mentioned that's a
good segue into the next one so we can
save some of the questions for the next
pause too
yeah that's it yes thank you if
if you see something in the in this
section that sparks in a further
conversation on that previous question
or any other question let's put in the
chat
we'll address it
and uh now makes a good point if you are
doing a machine learning type of thing
you do want to separate your test and
train
that's i feel like that's that's a whole
topic of its own so i won't go there but
yes you should
um okay
so we were talking about summarizing
the the time series data
and in in the
utility space i found that this is
probably the most common way to do that
it's called a daily load profile
it is a way to summarize the consumption
information
to easily see
uh trends right and there's a couple
different ways to do this load has
different definitions and
consumption demand
the approach here the functional data
analysis technique it works for however
you choose to summarize the data
um
i'm in marketing so i tend to use the
mean or some kind of like centrality
type measure b media to summarize but
you could do the max if you're
more focused on
the grid and electrical generation
capacity
what's the maximum
load that the system can handle or you
can do the average
however that's defined mean meaning
and once you have these low profiles
you can connect the dots like we talked
about functional data analysis that was
one of the questions how many how many
points do you need
as little as whatever you have 24
in this case or as many as you have
you can build confidence intervals
and i find that's useful instead of just
providing a point estimate we want to
provide a little bit more clarity as to
what's the variance look like
and then
the daily load profile is the most
classic
uh decomposition here but there are
others you can decompose it any other
way and if you if you're a little
familiar with time series you'll know uh
you'll know what kind of what that means
i don't want to i don't get into that
too much here but
essentially what you're doing is
decomposing the time series
and summarizing it in some way
this is our first example
this is time series information this is
an actual customer's
meter reads
this is only two weeks i'm working with
about two years worth of data on the
back end that would look very messy if i
plotted the whole thing but this is
essentially
the underlying data structure it's a
time series
uh you can see there's
like
it's not really upward trending or
anything but there's some cyclicality to
it those ups and downs so if you study
time series you can look this and you
can extract information from it
but it's useful to summarize and
decompose this information and that's
where this daily little profile load
profiles in general come in
that's step one we're gonna decompose
that time series
and what you're looking at here is
uh two years worth of meter reads
uh on the x-axis you have your day 24
hours of the day
and your measure of consumption on the y
axis each dot represents
a
a meter read for a particular day and
hour right so you have about
700 days plotted here
okay
step one step two we're going to apply
functional data analysis
and i don't show how to do that or
anything this is
just a showcase what you can do with it
and this always makes me chuckle because
it looks like
uh static on the screen kind of artsy if
you've ever seen those uh
those memes or
about uh deep learning art and whatever
that looks like on the back end it kind
of looks like this it's funny
um
so what we've done is we fit
a functional curve to every day right so
for the last two years worth of meter
reads
we've fit a curve to every one of those
days
and uh you can you can see a couple
things from here you know i don't get
too into that but it looks like at the
bottom portion of consumption so from
between 0 and 400 is where the majority
of the consumption for this particular
customer in the last few years is and
there's some there's some
like outliers i guess
out beyond that 400 range
step 3 is summarize right because this
is useful in to do a couple different
things like we talked about you can
summarize these curves you can summarize
all these curves into a single curve you
can build confidence intervals
i would never present this to a
stakeholder because they would look at
you like you're crazy
but this
is much more uh readable right so we've
summarized all those curves to produce a
point estimated curve right we fit the
curve to these 24 dots
from the meter reads we
extracted
the standard deviation or the variance
component because we had all those
curves we were able to build confidence
intervals around that
it allows us to answer
questions depending on
what that may be but you can say
something like
on average we are 95 confident that
consumption at this point in time is
between a and b right a little bit more
of a complete picture
and
that's the daily load profile right but
there are other ways to decompose a time
series you can do day week day month
month a year
be creative there might be
seasonal components
other than that
1 to 24 hour period
and the those three steps are the same
across
any of these decompositions
decompose
you choose your decomposition
you fit functional data analysis and
then you summarize
and
this is in part hosted by our studio so
i as i was putting this together i
thought well one thing you could do was
decompose the time series in a couple of
different ways collect those
decompositions
put them together in some in a shiny app
dashboard
and you would very quickly have
a rough idea as to what the average
behavior for a customer is for example
the frown on the top left
i probably wouldn't use a line for this
but you could maybe bar chart would be
more appropriate but you see that for
this customer it's a business customer
and you see that consumption is highest
between monday and friday and there's an
interaction effect on the weekends right
consumption drops at the weekends on the
bottom right you see the month and
consumption tends to be higher on
average in the winter months versus the
summer
so just kind of useful to see
experimenting with different things
playing around
it's a very flexible technique
okay second pause
if there are any questions
yes there's a few other questions coming
in on slido but just want to let
everyone know again too if you want to
raise your hand on zoom
or jump in live feel free to do so as
well
but the other questions were
so one was often with meter readings you
can have a lot of noise do you need to
clean the data in advance to remove
outliers and other noise in your data
good question um
so we have a whole
i guess let's answer that in two parts
in the first part
the raw meter reads are
cleaned up from a production system by
our engineers
so i'm extracting this from an already
cleaned state in a database somewhere
i
i don't do too much outside of that
whatever they've done i don't do too
much
i just take it all the way and because
i'm summarizing that information if
there are outliers they're kind of
taken care of by averaging right
if you're afraid of
uh if you're afraid that there are too
many outliers instead of summarizing by
the mean you can do the median
or you can do a pre-processing step to
say
you want to use
there's so many different ways to
define an outlier however you choose you
can pre-process and eliminate those data
points and then just work with what
remains
um but i didn't do any of that here i
used
the whole two years
thank you yeah there's one other
question that was can the fda approach
be used to estimate deviations from the
norm like theft of electricity
i would imagine um
it's it's a pretty robust
technique
i haven't done any sort of anomaly
detection
um
but i would imagine
you could
um
for example if you had an estimate of
what normal consumption is and then all
of a sudden there's a spike you would
see that right because if you if you
built a
uh
confidence interval around what you
thought to be true consumption true
behavior
built your confidence interval to be
like super wide 99 right
then
if something did come in that was way
outside that band it might be
cause to red to flag it and investigate
it further
um but i haven't done too much of that
oh there you go kelly thank you
pca
uh yes a lot a lot of the that's a good
point a lot of the techniques you're
used to
principal component analysis clustering
now other things they have functional
counterparts
that might be worth exploring
awesome okay
keep going
uh derivatives i found this to be really
interesting
um
i
outside of calculus
didn't think i would use derivatives at
work
it turns out to be really useful
and
one of the things i'm working on now is
sort of a feature engineering technique
to build the features for
machine learning
predictive
type word
and i'll show you a little bit about
what i mean by that
and
it's just opened up a new realm of
analysis for me that i've been
fascinated by
and we're going to revisit this we fit
this uh this curve to this customer
and now we're going to
uh differentiate this curve and we're
going to look at
the
velocity and acceleration of this
particular customer right so this
average
average behavior curve
and there's a couple interesting things
here if you look at the
max velocity and the minimum right these
global global extrema
and you're almost able to describe some
of the behavior of the customer right so
you can say something like
uh perhaps on peak hours for this
particular customer is between 8 am and
5 pm
now knowing that this is a business
customer you're like yeah that makes
sense um and if you wanted to do
for fun if you were doing calculus
you could do the second derivative test
right where the first derivative is zero
look at the second derivative is it
greater than zero or less than zero that
tells you something about whether that
that time is a max or a minimum
it's kind of cool
next this is a classic this is new to me
this is a classic uh way of looking at
derivative information in engineering
and physics
and it it's the same information we just
looked at but it's slightly presented in
a different manner
it's really good for cyclical type data
in this case it works really nicely
consumption and meter read type data and
what you see is what we said earlier all
the way to the right on the positive on
the x axis you have velocity you see
eight this eight am is max velocity
if we look all the way to the left we
see 5 p.m minimum velocity
and then you see these these cycles
almost these circles right you have this
big circle to the right in the positive
velocity section you have a small circle
center around zero maybe like a plateau
in consumption and then you have two
periods of ramping down
in consumption one bigger than the other
and that's essentially what's happening
here right
between the hours of 4 and 10 a.m
the consumption for this particular
customer on average starts to ramp up
and peaks at 8 am
and then between
uh
somewhere in the midday it plateaus
then you have two periods of ramping
down the primary ramping down period is
between about two
to
eight pm
six seven yes about eight pm then you
have this final ramping down for the day
it's almost like they're closing up shop
for the end of the day
that's pretty interesting i personally
never looked at it this way i find it
really interesting to describe behavior
um customer behavior in this way
and it's another
uh descriptive feature
to add information in context to any
analysis you're doing
and we can translate translate this back
to the original
the original data right
we have those four periods the first
period of the day is ramping up
you have this plateau in consumption
that primary ramp down
and then you have that closing up shop
period and then the cycle repeats
ramp up plateau ramp down ramp down but
i found this really fascinating i
thought this was really cool
um one of the things i am working on
on this as a proof of concept at work is
to extract those uh global extrema
using the first derivative as
individual on peak periods
for example right now
a consumer's energy let's say we have
a predefined window for what we call
on-peak hours for residential customers
um i don't remember how we came up with
those but let's say
from a to b
well that's very broad and we ask
customers to fit into that mold but
using something like derivatives you can
you can define what odd peak hours are
for each customer so you can be hyper
personalized be much more
customer-centric
so i'm building something now building a
data set for all our customers to define
those on personal on-peak
hours to potentially use and explore and
as features in other type of works
let's see
i'll stop there
any questions any thoughts
i don't see other questions specific to
the top oh i see um
rajiv you just asked a question
on slido would you want to jump in and
ask it live
i can't oh i don't have a mic i'll ask a
question but it is what are the
approaches to account for
he oh my gosh i'm not going to say this
word for my heterogeneity other than
fitting separate models to investigate
interactions with some x variable like
location uh good question i don't i
haven't done too much of that my uh
there's functional regression which
would would help you with that
um if i understood what you're saying
correctly if you had other components
and you wanted to do some sort of
functional
uh analysis with you could use
functional regression it's very similar
to what you're used to just with
and a layer up in abstraction with
functions or curves as opposed to
individual um features
kelly again for the win thank you i
haven't used
a pca on my own
uh i know it does does it on the back
end but i haven't done that too much my
own um
what else
awesome i see coran current emma
apologies if i mispronounce your name
you have your hand raised if you want to
jump in
hi
i i really like the idea can you hear me
yes i can yes i really like the idea
about using the derivative to find um
the peak periods so i was thinking of if
i have
meter reads from let's say 100 customers
and then i wanted to find which
customers have the same peak periods so
i could see relatively how i could do it
for one and then
do it for all of them but how
my general idea is i think i can write a
code which would give me
okay these customers are always
these are the serial numbers of the
meters of customers who have pictures
between eight and five these are
customers which i take periods between
six and ten
i i don't know that's what i was
thinking
is that something where you think this
can be applied
that's a good question and it's very uh
pressing it that's actually exactly what
i'm working on right now
is once you've defined it's almost two
steps right once you've defined these
on-peak periods for all customers
you can
you can
aggregate that information to construct
group level
um
on-peak periods right so let's say i
have for in your example 100 meter reads
i've defined what the antique periods
are using derivatives
then you can do one of two things really
you for your purpose you would probably
just cluster um
you could just cluster that information
and see which
customers
have similar on peak periods um
what else could you do that's probably
that's probably how i would approach
that problem and then i'm working on a
internal white paper that does that very
thing actually it's uh
it it clusters
uh
about like 60 000 customers worth of
information
and
defines on peak periods for each cluster
does that answer the question is that
kind what you're thinking
yes yes because um the type of data i
work with is renewable energy so we
wanted to know which people are using so
will be best fit for solar energy
because there are peak periods in the
day time which people will be there for
other types of energy because their own
peak period is in different
yeah so that's where i was heading
mm-hmm
yeah that's um actually
the questions have been great that's a
perfect segue into the next section
there's been some recent research um
about
clustering these curves so you could for
example
fit a curve to all of your 100 customers
and then cluster the curves themselves
as opposed to
treating the
time series measurements let's say you
had 24 hours instead of treating 24
hours as individual features
that are highly correlated you can
cluster the curves
and funny enough that is the next
section
um
almost like you timed it out perfectly
yeah and it's
it's almost as i've been learning this
is this uh this technique and applying
this
the fitting of the curves kind of like
that connecting the dots derivatives and
then clustering has been my progression
through this learning process
uh the first thing was just getting
comfortable and fitting the curves
trying different ways to fit the curves
for your for your bases
cubic splines wavelets you name it and
then getting the derivative information
how is that useful building use cases
kind of
showing the utility
and then the question came up just like
yours well what else can we do with that
and it just
it just occurred to me well i'm in
marketing
a lot of what we do is segmentation and
clustering we want to be more targeted
in our messaging and all that
[Music]
can we cluster this information we
cluster this stuff and it turns out you
can
and for this i'm using the hello world
example
of functional data analysis
there is a package in r called fda in it
there's this data if you want to
get in and play with it
it's from
um
it's canadian it's average canadian
weather temperature
uh for
i think 36 or 50 some number of canadian
stations some weather stations in canada
for a year right so they've averaged
this kind of like it looks almost like a
low profile but instead of being hours
you're looking at days in the year and
they've averaged the temperatures that
the red line there is the average of the
group
and
before i proceed take a look at this and
ask yourselves if you had
two crayons or coloring pencils or
pencils whatever
and i asked you to color in the lines
based on how you would group these
things into two different groups
how would you do that right
keep that in mind
um how we've done it traditionally at
work has been to treat the
features
in this case uh hours of the year or
days of the year uh in my case it's been
hours in the day
24 in this example it's
one through 365
treat those features as features in a
clustering uh in a traditional
clustering process
the features are highly correlated right
they're dependent on each other so you
use some kind of dimension reduction
technique principal component analysis
for example in this case i extracted two
pcs that was like 95 or 97 of the
variance
and this is what comes out
and it looks
it looks like it makes sense right so
there's not really any questions that
looks um
pretty straightforward and this is
your traditional clustering pca
dimension reduction if you need it and
you do need it and then k-means you can
probably do higher echo clustering as
well extract to
so many different approaches it's just k
means
and then
this is relatively newer
this is clustering the curves themselves
the uh something that's a library and
are called fun hddc
um i think i think the first paper
describing this came out
2017 2015 maybe i'm not sure but it's
recent
and it does something very similar
but in a from a functional
perspective and
it looks very different from the
the clustering outcome looks very
different from
the traditional clustering measurement
so this is this is why early on i said
it's another tool in your tool box
um
different results no depends on your use
case
maybe this better aligns with your what
your needs are
to me when i looked at that black and
white curve the black and white lines
originally this aligns more with what i
thought was funny enough
but then i've asked others in
preparation for the presentation and
they said the traditional lined up more
with what they thought that's kind of
interesting um
that is it for that section i don't i
haven't explored this too in depth i do
have
another project i'm working on with a
colleague to uh build this out in more
detail
in comparing the different approaches
to see if this curve clustering idea is
something that we want to adopt
and replace
or have in addition to
our traditional clustering
processes
awesome i know on the topic of packages
as you just mentioned fda someone else
had asked
are there other packages that you could
recommend to us for functional data
analysis
yeah absolutely um
fda's classic
matthew mentions the refund the package
that's really good
um
there's a supplemental package to fda
called fda
dot
usc i think and it gives you a little
bit more uh functionality for example in
fda you can average the curves through
the mean
with this supplemental
package you can do
the median and a bunch of other stuff
there's a couple clustering actually
if you wait a second i
have resources um i would recommend to
visit the r cran task view this is
really neat they have a running list of
all available functional data analysis
libraries in r that's um
that's how i discovered the clustering
fortune i there's a small snippet there
that describes the different techniques
for curve clustering
um
let's see
hey i would say just visit that explorer
um
i got started
on this journey
uh in school actually we were learning
about splines
and uh gams generalized additive models
and i was really interested with the
idea and i asked my professor where i
can get more information about
functional data analysis and my
professor pointed me towards work uh
work by professor ramsey
so i purchased these two books here
functional data analysis it's
theoretical it's the math behind things
it's really good for understanding
what the heck's going on in the
background
for an applied perspective functional
data analysis with r
in matlab is a great resource i actually
have it right here
i was doing something this morning with
it and i reference that all the time
there are also really great
public posts
joseph
i believe is an art studio employee he
has three or four posts on our views
that are really good
um
[Music]
there's an online course that's in-depth
and quite lengthy and i'm sure it would
cover your questions there's if you're
interested in gams specifically
um there's a great course by noam ross
on that information
um there are other books too that are
really good that i haven't purchased
i've only stuck with these two
and then the r in in summary the r
ecosystem for functionality analysis is
really rich if you want to do something
it's there
um
and then i do know there are a few
resources in python as well
[Music]
and that
is it that's all i had
thank you so much santiago i
that was awesome i see there's a lot of
other great questions here too
but on that topic of all those great
resources i did just want to say to
everyone as well if you have other
things to share too feel free to put
them into the chat as well or other
things that have been helpful for you
and in learning fda
yeah there's a
there's a joseph one of joseph's post on
our new the army's blog
shows a
uh
it looks like um
i'm trying on i'm trying to blank on the
name but it's a map
of
uh
how the different packages relate to
each other and at the center is the
refund package that's getting a lot of
love in the chat uh
chat section but also fda the fda
package and the refund package are
pretty much the source of all newer
works
it's really cool i would say check that
out that's a really neat
image
um
yeah there's a lot of happening the
ecosystem's so rich explore if you're
interested
thank you
let me go over to some of the slido
questions
and as a reminder you can always raise
your hand on zoom too if you want to ask
live
um
let's see
their question was on the weather time
series analysis
[Music]
let's see
the weather time series analysis based
on what criteria
will we give color i'm not understanding
the question exactly
so feel
feel free to weigh in
if you want to add any other context
to that question too or santiago if you
understand what they might be asking
there i think i get it
in the traditional clustering
paradigm
you can since our features are so
related you're dealing with collinearity
um dimension reduction is almost
a necessity right
so using pca on the features treating
them like independent features
and extracting
some pcs is the way to go and that's
i would say
i think that answers that question from
a traditional perspective
from a curved clustering perspective
it's doing pretty much the same thing
it's doing like you've seen in the chat
probably a functional pca it's doing
that on the background in the back end
too
um and extracting some kind of
variants and
extracting the pcs based on some kind of
variance metric maybe i honestly haven't
explored
the inner workings too much um i find it
useful to focus on applications first
and if it's if i can do if i can do it
first of all and then um
and then
i can it meets my needs then i go back
and i start reading a little bit more
about the information the details uh for
example i've read the research paper a
little bit to understand what's going on
like what's the background
and it's pretty it's pretty
understandable if you have some
understanding of like it's not it's not
so academic that it's beyond reach um
for example the f
fun hddc has a has uh their papers it's
pretty approachable i would say check it
out to have a good understanding of what
it's doing but it
it's it's like the functional
counterpart
the traditional clustering it's doing
very similar things
thank you
i see someone else said i know the gams
course or gam
what is the difference between gams and
fda are they the same thing
sort of
um
gam yeah i mean yes i guess in short yes
um
gams use cubic splines so that if you
remember that uh that early math formula
the linear combination if you think of
like the regression component you have
your intercept and then you have beta
you give your coefficient times some
data coefficient times
that fee function builds out
um
the the data component the nonparametric
data component right that non-parametric
function there are different ways to fit
that in gams
i don't know if you can switch that
um i've only ever seen it with cubic
splines
in which case that is fda that is
functional data analysis
um
let's see you could generalize further
and do maybe like um
functional regression on your own using
the functionality analysis techniques
um and then define the feed function as
whatever you wanted for your the fourier
series wavelets monotone polynomial
whatever
but i think gams specifically use cubic
fonts
thank you uh thomas i saw you had your
hand raised earlier um if you want to
jump in with your question
or maybe it was answered from slido but
feel free to to jump in again
but kelly i see you just asked a
question in the chat too if you want to
ask live
oh i can always ask the questions for
people too feel free to put a little
like i should have said that sorry a
star next to your question if you ask in
the zoom chat too and want me to ask it
um the question was curious to know if
anyone also tried using uh wavelet for
curve modeling
i haven't yet um
in
one of the textbooks by professor ramsey
he touts it as uh
that's supposed to be pretty good i
haven't really worked with it too much
i've mostly stuck with the four-year
series the four-year
basis expansion and
cubic splines
for me
for meter reads i found the four-year uh
series the four-year basis functions
work really well
um and accepted rare cases where
um like i've seen this in i've seen this
in business customers more where
consumption could be
uh
randomly let me plug the thoughts the
fourier series works really well for
periodic data right because it's built
by sines and cosines and but it doesn't
do very well when things are like if
something's jagged it doesn't jump up
through what doesn't adjust up to these
um
there's a turn but i'm thinking like
if your consumption was like this right
you go from nothing straight up back
down these very jagged rises and peaks
before your series won't approximate
that very well cubic swines would fit
that much better
um
but there are downsides to that too
right uh
you just have to account for different
different
differentiability if that's what you're
interested in
or
um the end points with cubic explains to
be kind of wonky so if you're trying if
you're doing something there that might
get weird
um
[Music]
well thank you so much um i think
oh there was a question earlier um
from someone that was more related to
a coding question the anonymous question
was
they need to know how to change the data
class for all variables
from double to original class
without doing it manually when they
import a csv file and a few people were
helping in the chat as well
their question
further question was
they want to change
everything for like 50 variables at once
and how to do that
[Music]
i know it's hard to kind of ask coding
questions here it does
does that make sense okay yeah it's
actually pretty easy um and
all thanks to
the tidy verse funny enough so shout out
our studio
um
using stuff like
uh the across function d play r across
you select your fields for example if
you were interested in
uh if it was all fields it'd be super
easy if you needed a certain number of
fields you could do something like deep
like r across
uh columns select where contains for
example if you have a set prefix or
suffix or something and then function
would be whatever you need to justify
um
i i so as part of this uh since i'm
using actual customer information
uh i have to add noise to me compliance
standards and all that stuff
and i i take i do that very thing i take
i read in the date of the raw data and
then i do
using the tight inverse i do the cross
function apply noise
um
and then that just takes care of
everything automatically there's
probably other ways to do it but the
tidy burst would be
probably my go-to it's easy
thank you and i just want to make sure
that answered whoever's question
that was
feel free to
respond back anonymously and slide out
to and if not you can always
ask me one on one as well
um
and then another question was how often
do you need to refit the curves
or clustering
um
it depends it's almost
uh if i were to generalize that a little
bit further if you were
depending on what you were doing if you
were doing a one-off analysis then only
once right if you were putting this into
production to do something um like
predicting something or clustering into
customers then
you're entering a broader conversation
about when do you re-tune models in
general
right so if you're doing something in
production you should have uh some sort
of like data drift
type uh pipelines that assess as your
data changed um there's a previous
comment about outliers if
if
if your input data has tended to be one
way and then all of a sudden just
behavior changes let's say do the code
or something something else
then it's probably time to retune right
you should have a flag that says hey
just a heads up or even break your
procedure to say uh your input data is
way different than what it used to be
that's kind of like a broader topic
there's no i don't think there's a set
defined period
but there's a lot of research out there
to help guide that conversation as to
when how often
and it probably depends on the nature of
your data too if you're doing something
at the daily level it's probably more
frequent if you're working on aggregate
aggregated yearly meter reads then
once or twice a year once or twice a
year would probably suffice
awesome thank you uh quran tema i see
you have your hand raised too if you
want to jump in
hi
uh yes i was still thinking about the
clustering and i was thinking about what
if there's a [ __ ] there's sort of bias
in the data in in terms of for my 100
customers i do not have data
the same amount of data first one
customer i only have data for one month
and then maybe a couple of days in one
month and for some customers i have
every day for six months and like for
that variation would that affect in the
clustering
uh it shouldn't
the
the functional data analysis techniques
are really robust
um from in my case since i'm since i've
typically worked with uh like i'll prep
the data right i will look at only
customers who have had at least six
months of meter reads
um
i'll eliminate anywhere where
consumption is zero because some people
might just activate a meter never use it
right get rid of those people
so if you pref
i've used uh
what do you call it uh equally spaced
basis functions um like the
the they're called knots
uh the number of knots
can be equally spaced in my case for
example in this in the presentation
today they're 24
right because i'm working with 24 hours
of the day so i define a knot at each
hour of the day but let's say in your
case you had
month one month two month five month
seven month twelve and you wouldn't use
equal means based knots because you
don't have them
what you might do is
fit curves individually to each customer
using
whatever data you do have whatever like
whatever periods you have right whatever
knots you have to find those for each
and each customer and then
work with those uh
the respective curves
um
for for example with my work since i
don't have that issue i can work with
all the customers at once
and that uh in a
no
and actually in the white paper i was
telling you about i'm working with it's
about 60 000 customers yeah so it's a
matrix of by 60 to 60 thousand and by
it's either way it's 24 and by
60 000 p right so my customers are my
features they're really wide i can just
treat them all at once because the data
is the same
that's 20 they have some data for all 24
hours it makes it really easy
um in your case the only thing that
really switches is
you might have to fit
the curves to each individual customer
and then work with that the output like
those
those curves as opposed to working with
them all at once
thank you let me just check to see if
there are other questions i know a few
people have to
drop right at the top of the hour so
just did just want to let you know i
shared a few links in the chat if you
ever want to provide feedback for the
meetups
if you are interested in speaking at a
future meetup whether that's
energy or another industry that you work
in
and then also a calendar of upcoming
events too
one last question that was on the slide
of santiago was someone asked if you
would be able to share this code for
them to try it or if you have that
shared on github somewhere
i don't
um
only because it's
it's customer information
i don't i had
i had to meet compliance needs and
standards and go through a whole
process
so i don't know if i can share
i can certainly share the presentation
but i don't know if i can share
any code
i might be able to create a markdown
type file and just hide that chunk so
you don't see anything there but still
show the steps after the fact i might be
able to do that but i don't know
thank you i can follow up with you after
and
um i'll share all the resources and
slides with the recording as well so
that will go up to the rstudio youtube
and i'll put that playlist here for all
the meetups
in the chat too
um
so i'll work on hopefully sharing that
by the end of the day tomorrow too
i'll do one last check for for any
questions feel free to unmute yourself
and jump in
try to count at least seven seconds here
thank you so much santiago for an
awesome presentation and
and sharing all those resources with us
too
yeah we appreciate it
thank you everybody
thank you
[Music]
you